Now that we have seen what
a relational database looks like,
we said it's a collection
of relations or tables, and
we looked at a table, and tuples, and
at the various attributes and so on.
So, what kind of operations
can you perform on tables?
Of course you can create a table.
We're talking about selecting certain
information out of a table of relations.
So for example, I can say everybody
who is in a certain department,
we can read that information
out of that relation.
That's what a query selection will do,
and
we going to see examples
of that will return.
So you can select information, you
can of course insert tuples, or rows,
you can update attribute
values that are in there.
You can actually perform joint
operations across multiple tables and,
of course, you can delete tuples,
delete tables and
eventually delete a database,
that may be a collection of tables.
You know, create, delete are sort of
similar to what we have seen before, for
example, files.
But some of the things like select,
insert, join, these are kind of
new to how you can manipulate and access
data that is stored in a data base.
What I do for,
we said we write queries or
programs to access data that is stored
in a data base and those programs or
queries can actually make use of these
operations that we're talking about.
So this is saying select, star means
everything, so all attribute values.
>From the employee table that we
had where the department ID is 15.
So we are saying basically tell us,
give us the information about
every employee who works in
department that has ID 15.
So this is an example of how
I might access information
that is told in the relation or
the table that we just saw.
And this is an example of a read query,
because all we're doing is reading
selected pieces of information
that is there in that table.
And returning that to whoever
is making this request.
So actually if you are going to run this
query against the table
that we just saw.
You'll see that the department ID is
15 for two employees, Robin and Cody.
So we are going to get the tuples for
Robin and Cody.
In response to, when we run this query
against the database that we have.
So selection has happened because,
of course, we had a lot more employees.
Now we're only selecting the ones who
work in the department with ID 15,
who happen to be these two people.
And these are return of the programs,
the queries that return in a language,
a query language.
We talked about SQL before, and
we'll see some more examples of that.
But basically these programs or
queries that we're talking about in
this language allow you to
use these basic operations.
That you can perform on
tables of relations and
you can use these operations in
the programs that you write or
the queries that you submit to access
the data that is of interest to you.